[Music]
for the theme of st patrick's day i
wrote you guys some toasts which we can
do with this shot
in the style of a limerick
oh so you wrote these i wrote these
limericks for each of you but i think
that you shouldn't read the one that's
about you should read one that's about
megan this is really good megan you're a
delightful writer she's the best
who's going first who's going first i'll
go first okay because i i i don't expect
my ability to continue to speak
coherently
let's raise our glasses to glenn
the best of the five star men
he's the host of this show
can't stay safe on the snow
and he dreams
of not chewing again
megan that's very so good that's very
very good yeah a lot of references and
if somebody at home doesn't think that
it's good they're [ __ ] idiots
it's very good cheers cheers we'll go a
little bit for this one because then we
got three did i already drink mine you
said you didn't want it
i don't remember rob read yours
three cheers for our pal
charlie day yeah he's one of a kind
in a way
we'd flatter him more
but he'll walk out the door
and forget every word that we said
wait so good it's like god damn that's
good why did i forget something
that is good
well rob that means this one's about you
i guess so
you want to hear it
yes
what are you anticipating
well
out of the three of us yeah i'm the one
that's closest to megan oh so you're
anticipating a roast
i think it's going to be
roast devastating yeah roasty yes
but we have
we're very close so she also loves you
oh yeah we love each other very much
it's a love-hate relationship as it
often is yes but she does i'm i'm
guessing she doesn't love you she likes
you but she doesn't know you that well
not not i mean right now i love
everybody yeah yeah
but you're keeping her
because of your sociopathy you're
keeping her that's not sociopathy that's
not
that's not sociopathy that's growing up
in an air force family where you moved
around a lot and how to protect yourself
god that's a whole thing okay all right
that's the whole thing that we can get
into that but i hold everyone at arm's
length got it
okay and i don't like that about myself
i
it's ingrained okay uh a toast to our
good buddy rob
he's the reason we all got this job
thank god he made sonny to prove that
he's funny
because little rose a big rose because
his other show
makes people sob
[Music]